ich bin jetzt ich finde sie mal ich bin
felix
hier in berlin
in bali genau es sieht ein wenig aus wie
mit dem pool wie ein wie in bali aber es
ist berlin wo ich die kleinstadthelden
aus bremen aufgegabelt habe da sind sie
was hat euch hierhin verschlagen wo sind
wir hier überhaupt
ich weiß gar nicht genau wie der klub
sich ausspruch ich glaub stage club und
wir sind heute abend zum konzert zu
spielen und warum sei noch nicht auf dem
weg wo ist nicht in der otto aber in der
nähe quatsch platz in der in der max
schmeling halle ist schmeling hat wir
haben ja noch ein bisschen zeit wir
sehen ja noch eine woche vorher und wir
sind jetzt gerade dabei so ein bisschen
die bundesländer abzuklappern spiel noch
ein paar konzerte sind froh dass wir mit
der neuen platte im gepäck uns mal
zeigen dürfen auf der straße oder hat zu
uns nach berlin verschlagen wie sind die
reaktionen sehr gut also wirklich also
wir haben ja in den letzten jahr schon
viele lieder gespielt jetzt auf dem
neuen album sind und es ist jetzt ein
gutes gefühl dass die leute auch
bekannte lieder dann
zum tanzen da haben es ist ja immer so
die alten lieder sind immer besser
angekommen würde so konnten mit singen
und so weiter und jetzt ist es langsam
so dass sie das zweite album gestern
habe ich schon die ersten lippen tanzen
sehen und lieder vom zweiten album
worden mitgesungen lassen schön das
gefühl also er rechnet euch gute chancen
aus oder seit der außenseiter ja das
weiß man ja immer nicht das wunder von
der weser wir wollen da nichts
ausschließen
mal gucken also bremen hat er letzte
saison nicht so kanal mäßig abgeliefert
und der olympische gedanke zählt bei uns
aber alles ist drin was macht euch so
einzigartig
ja ich habe es nicht ganz verstanden was
sie ist das gerade
was früher nicht die kleinsten nein er
ist die us krampe okay ein guter mann
okay gut er war macht im juli was macht
euch so aktie hatte ich
ja wir sind vier verschiedene typen die
irgendwie jeder ihren einfluss mit in
die band einfließen lassen deswegen ist
das album ist zweiteres scharmbeck was
übrigens am 19 rausgekommen ist auch so
vielseitig und wir sind irgendwie nicht
so eine band gesagt wir wollen jetzt in
die ecke oder in die ecke ist es kann
morgen wieder woanders hingehen und wir
sind immer offen für neues und machen
das was uns gefällt was uns ausmacht und
deswegen sind wir denke ich mal
einzigartig also kleinstadthelden gibt's
einfach nur einmal weil wir hier
belaufen
ok so ich habe ja es scheint nicht ganz
auf ihr kommt aus bremen tritt für
bremen an aber das ist ein kleiner
vorort prämisse kleine vor ort genau
aber kleinstadthelden in bremen
osterholz scharmbeck das ist sozusagen
unsere heimatstadt in der wir zum teil
aufgewachsen sind und sind jetzt wahl
bremer und sind froh dass wir für bremen
ins rennen gehen super wir drücken euch
die daumen und es gibt noch jemand der
euch die daumen drückt kann die
codemeter von youtube hey ich bin cardio
bekannt als kultur- und ich unterstütze
das produkt oder die aktion vorne
während kleinstadthelden aus bremen beim
bundesvision songcontest
wir sagen danke und an euch zuschauer am
ersten zehn ist es soweit die finger
sollen wund telefoniert werden und wir
hoffen ihn ruft für uns an und wenn wir
das ding tatsächlich mit nach hause
nehmen dann machen wir eine dicke party
in bremen und cuddy du bist recht
herzlich eingeladen